[Music]
tommy i called you to talk about dad and
money
dad owns a hundred bitter coins and he's
got him in a wallet on the internet the
wallet's the internet
what the [ __ ] are you talking about if
we get the password
there's millions of dollars in there
elon musk
started a new type of money who is elon
musk he was an astronaut tommy
[Music]
why don't you try [ __ ] susan that was
his girlfriend's baby
that's not a bad idea this is tracy come
on
we never had nothing growing up but now
we can have something
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] loser what's the
password what's the [ __ ]
password how many central banks are
[ __ ] us
it would change our [ __ ] lives i have
70 dollars
that's not good big [ __ ] surprise
there your father was a real class act
you're gonna be okay tommy it's gonna be
okay
we're trying to get the password say
[Music]
something